[Musique]
n'essayez il reste deux boîtes
vous avez pris la boîte 9 ou la boîte
fin il reste un week end à menton avec
les bogdanov ou le prime time sur ces 8
maxime galy vous avez gagné le pire
feuille ciseaux le pfc c'est donc vous
qui avez le droit de choisir de garder
cette boîte ou de la donner vous avez
laisser une dernière chance et vous
m'avez dix ans je garde cette boîte
c'était une chance je les sais ce que
vous allez partir en week end avec les
bogdanov ou est-ce que c'est matthieu
delormeau qui va partir en week-end avec
les bogdanoff
est ce que vous allez animer le prime ou
est-ce que ces matchs de l'en but many
et de son bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et moi j'ai déjà le concept si jamais à
vous donner des idées
c'est quoi le concept s'est alors
rapidement avec de mesurer ma télé girl
c'est moi canine et je m'entoure que
deux bombes qui est lié à gastes que de
bons drame
non j'ai déjà posé la question il est
nommé nommé ce jour là ne peut pas elle
m'a dit mais ça c'est péché non non pas
du tout sinon j'aurais adoré mais je me
revois la mater les girls cinq fils à
cinq fils a alors un concept dont vous
voyez j'ai fait par pierre ménès
ce sera un divertissement on irait les
débats enflammés en parlerait musée qui
auraient des tours de magie
juste à côté j'espère que vous avez le
menton gagner oui est ce que tu veux
changer
non il oppose la question une dernière
fois un dernière fois sur la tête de ma
mère sera la dernière fois que le russe
maxim gainey les deux me vont
est-ce que vous gardez cette boîte haut
ce que voulait changer matthieu
delormeau il a perdu deux fois une fois
en dernière boîte deux fois et le prime
allait passer sous peu son père y
travaille depuis deux ans une tragédie
et oui on s'était dit de sa tante un
gentleman qui comprend au 1o amicalement
merci c'est bon alors
allez allez en l'honneur de cette bougie
vais conserver cette voie death and
bones papa gâteau électriques ont voulu
donner plus bien d'après midi dans la 6
cela ce sont celles là franchement je
serais sans doute est ce que vous aimez
agathe j'adore bien sûr est ce que vous
êtes couturier kelly et coupe à eilat et
son moi je n'ai pas la pression est
énorme ça va ya pas non plus d une
enquête doit telle qu'on l'a connue mais
imagine les yeux en tunisie bien mais
c'est vraiment un truc résout pas dit
oui
les dons
non pas savoir comme un gardon mais qui
dit je te jure on va plus bas c'est aux
fléchettes j'ai un prime unique le
garder je le sens qu'est-ce qui est le
plus marrant agathe c'est plus marrant
que mathieu passe à côté du prévenu une
troisième fois
oui dieu si je fais le prime t dessus
mais aussi d'ailleurs
on s'en fout aller à bamako ouais
pourquoi il change pas mal mais si il
veut pas et veut pas témoigner coeur et
bien c'est fait chier que tu dis si par
hasard m'a fait plus d'audience que moi
et tout ça devient la vedette de ces
métiers on ya eu droit hier pas de
risque
la peur pour l'avenir
j'aurais tout essayé à tort d'avoir un
rival à nous j'aurais tout essayé à la
ils n'ont pas changé de boîte n'ont pas
fini d'agiter toi as-tu eu de leurs mots
mon chéri d'amour
enfin c'est votre boîte que je veux
ouvrir
il était temps kamanan maxi vraiment et
votre boîte tous mourir mon match je
vous rassure chéri d'amour la côte et de
syrie peut-être noms qui restent là on
va le voir longtemps il alors pendant
deux heures sur le prime time de leur
beau que je fais comment gagner a eu la
possibilité de changer sa boîte qui va
changer ma chance il faut changer ou pas
il a eu la possibilité de changer sa
boîte maxime guide mais qu'est ce qu'il
a fait a voulu garder sa boîte donc ici
sk le prime time
presque à l'abri québec les poteaux
[Applaudissements]
non
oh
[Applaudissements]
matthieu delormeau mon chéri et j'ai
tout fait pour que vous ayez preuve j'ai
pas tout fait j'ai tout fait oui il a
une tête dure celui-là s'ils avaient
tous dur comme sa tête il n'en fait pas